People are not fully rational and then
they do,
they make many choices that if they
reflected upon them they would do
differently.
There's no question about that and we
have a fair understanding actually of
what is happening,
at least at the individual level of my
senses that we have explored a lot of
what is happening.
I wouldn't say there's going to be no
further progress,
but we've explored in law,
um,
the major tendencies,
well the major tendencies to people tend
to frame things very narrowly.
They take a narrow view of decision
makings.
They look at the problem at hand and
they deal with it as if it were the only
problem.
Very frequently.
It's a better idea to look at problems
as they will recur throughout your life
and then you look at the policy that you
to adopt for a class of problems.
Difficult to do would be a better thing.
People frame things narrowly in the
sense,
for example,
they will save and borrow at the same
time instead of somehow treating their
whole portfolio of,
of assets as,
as one thing.
If people were able to take a broader
view,
they would in general make better
decisions.
So that is certainly one,
one of the weaknesses of human decision
making,
we call it narrow framing.
Mental accounting,
you know,
is is a big deal.
This is the way that we live.
So we have,
we have,
we keep our money in different mental
accounts for which we have different
rules,
so people will,
well of course they spend,
they're spending money.
Um,
but then there is a hierarchy of the
accounts that they will touch.
They will spend money that they've
stalled for vacation,
what often before they will spend
whatever they're thinking of a savings
for their children's education.
So those are mental accounts for which
people have different rules more
foolishly versus pretty sensible because
mental accounting is a tool of self
control.
But more foolishly,
investors tend to view each stock that
they buy as a mental account and they
want to sell it,
uh,
when it is a winner.
And so they tend to sell their winners
and hang on to their losers in their
portfolio.
And that turns out to make them
substantially poorer than if they had
done things differently.
And you need to be numerate for certain
kinds of decisions.
So numerous people have a significant
advantage over those who are not
understanding compounding compound
interest.
And it makes a huge difference whether
you're a credit card borrower or
somebody was saving.
People have a very hazy idea of compound
interest and,
and it's very,
so I would say that first of all you
need to be numerous that many people are
then,
then you need to frame things broadly.
I mean that's a,
it frequently goes with numeracy but
it's not quite the same thing.
Uh,
and then by taking the broad view,
it is very important not to have overly
strong emotional reactions to events.
And what I mean by that is that most of
us tend to respond to gains and two
losses,
two changes that happen in our life.
Actually,
you're better off if you frame things
broadly and you think you win a few,
lose a few,
and you have very limited emotional
response to small gains and two small
losses that tends to induce better
decision making.